the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
audio quality for this video is poor due
to technical difficulties one had to
cram all this stuff into one's mind
whether one like it or not
distortion has such a deterrent effect
that after I passed the final
examination I found the consideration of
any scientific problems distasteful to
me for an entire group who said that
Einstein it's a one of the greatest
scientists over the last three or four
hundred years so that was the effect of
regular school and education by nine
seconds and it wasn't it's not just
eyesight it's a general pattern so here
from Manchester New Hampshire in the
1930s it's how it was medicine
superintendent describes the children's
approach to learning and reading
interesting knowledge in the traditional
workplace when I asked children to tell
me what they do reading they were
hesitant embarrassed and did it in one
fourth grade I could not find a single
child who'd admit and committed the sin
of reading I did not have a single
volunteer when I tried to draft them the
children stood up their heads in the for
experimental work raised the children a
fairly thought to tell me what they
believed the outer closed in each case
with a dozen hands and waving in the air
and little faces crestfallen because we
the question is why where's of the
change in the effect of the formal
educational system so in revolutionary
America so this is Thomas Paine's Common
Sense their population now if you look
at Thomas Paine
these are very okay okay now 30% is a
very very big number especially
considering the level of proficiency
that's require a threshold pretty low
whereas back in 1770s America ten
million to 12 million people equivalent
of today while Thomas Paine's Common
Sense and probably many of them are not
actually there
so they were men that boat was led to
them so there was a green coverage for
words and ideas and learning which many
ways we have not matched despite or
because of the vast extent of the
schooling system and education so
suppose you want to change this you want
to improve the situation like to make
education better what are some of the
awesome I'm going to discuss the
obstacles in ascending order of
difficulty overcoming or sort of it in
another way to phrase it is ascending
order of how a local trail
so the first off I'm gonna discuss is
sort of its local to people individually
back and then I'll move to obstacles
that are driving this book so the first
obstacle is called cognitive dissonance
so the way to see this in action is
suppose you go to someone you say well
no the basic that course is done we
really improve we do this way and you
think you've made a perfect
is there all the psychologists and he
did the following so the experiments
were he had people come and do this task
where they basically just put round
square pegs in the square holes triangle
face of the triangular so how they did
the experiment they were then split into
two groups so they were passed to root
Oh No oh sorry
so the group a was just sent away
you made it an experiment and nothing
was willing to be so in 1950 we still
have the price of gold is fixed by Fiat
from Bretton Woods $35
so then what happened was these students
then did their work either nothing or is
that lead assistant and then they were
tested a year later about their opinion
of Easterners so that was actually the
real experiment so these students
thought you know like all psychology
experiments they thought they were
actually helping the people see so take
a minute or two trying to predict what
their know about cheeseburger or one
year leader
so you have item they were to give me
forgiveness would induce me
okay so the group seats maybe like get
more than you see that's the question is
who likes it more so they just Lucy
liked it more they weren't getting
enough incentive that's possible they
liked it originally but they piss
themselves we must have convinced
themselves because they
Oh per person B probably windows like as
much as they you know
the process of recruiting people would
get you to like it more because you have
to be 70 and the question is are you
whether you put more effort into that
I'll get legitimate then okay so this I
would say yes to me actually when you're
right actually what happened is that
these people still a lot of this boring
and these people like so just as you
predicted and basically so at the time
this was camera trigger and the whole
idea of cognitive dissonance was built
up to explain this conference we're
about to result which is why don't you
like it more when you're paid to and
it's exactly what we say which is that
further reason to yourself well if
they're giving me for Hunter yeah sure
you know but the ability give you 20
bucks says option C no of course II
wouldn't do that must be some reason
that we're doing that so if you're
participating in the activity that they
say by doing it with a blanket or at
least try to justify it yourself we need
some kind of justification and the
justification would be as well I'm doing
it because they paid a lot of money just
the easy lube receipt can't be back
because there isn't enough money so it
must be it's actually an intrinsically
worthwhile activity so depending shifts
now if you remember I mentioned Congress
business as one of the reasons to have
people vote when you're originally doing
multiple choice questions they are given
multiple choice
C or D the courts haven't invoke and
make a public stand is that it permits
them to the question into the answer
maybe now they have some public they
have some public appearance one of the
political organizers notice and these
kind of ideas are to hold hat now we've
seeped into the consciousness of
psychology and party so people will
sometimes for example come around and
ask you well would you mind putting a
society for this political candidate
would you mind putting a sign in their
front yard
so now what have you done made a public
commitment that everyone who drives by
or walks by see that sign for the
Kennedy
so now studies are completely consistent
in this you now do it you've not support
neck in it anymore so this turns out
what's the key thing in changing your
view is that you feel you have a choice
okay so here if you put a gun to
someone's head
put a sign in the front yard and they
put assignment doesn't change they chose
to do it now how's that linked to people
responsible you say yeah they were just
sent away they were passed nearly off to
see whether they what they bought it and
they said yes or no sort of control let
me do expectancy yeah
just the checks and no one could say
well maybe people find it really
fascinating you know so now what happens
when you say to someone oh but we really
should change the weight of course it's
there and that exposure at some leap
universities like MIT
people who teach these universities come
from either that same University
especially notorious I mean that a
justification for it which is that our
system is so alaq' different only people
go through that particular system and
possibly t-shirts so how are the
justification either people come from
that same place or come from a similar
background universe exactly so now
you're not criticizing a system that the
babe that ain't selected them right the
system selected them from among a whole
bunch of people and so by definition it
must be the system but also they now had
many opportunities to make public
commitments to the system the way things
are taught the way things are done right
they've talked in the classes they
participate crinkling discussions they
selected the students comical students
that would be better at supporting that
system so the result is that because
years of cognitive dissonance working on
people there they are now very very
convinced that the way things are done
right now is great and in this is all
the time in business it's not
necessarily a continent belief if you
ask them can you explain why it's great
give youth great reasons and this can be
very expedient to meet you into hot wok
so for example you say well you know
maybe we should teach this course
differently and put in interactive
questions the students learn them you'll
get responses that are almost nonsense
lovely things things like for example
well if we don't put everything on the
chalkboard or how will students know
what's going to be on the exam
and yeah it's a valid English sentence
but it's not going to be argument
because they're students those who say
look there's tons of answer to that
problem but this these kind of things we
offer as just a complete trump card okay
be nice of trumps to play to do now that
level of thought that's behind it no way
to look at that level of scientific
research serve and be successful
research but how come that's okay
is that reducing in this area well
because it's really not a cognitive
response to be made it's an emotional
it's a belief response you threatening
the challenged person's core beliefs and
they're not they're going to come out
and react very strongly if you try to
argue it just
actually which is how so what is this
discussion mean as an example
II was really worried about it great
well you can tell them the faculty look
then that 3% on that promise that it's
going to be 0.13% kinda great just total
points going anywhere anytime so that's
the faculty level you may find good
problem client than just the back the
discussion is just the tip of the
iceberg there's all this stuff going on
so what good this on this stuff well
emotional is basis feel really anxious
about great now why might that be well
that's the meaning may be that they feel
that the great measures how good they
are they've always thought no they got
it they might see my mistake and so it
so it's a similar thing with the
discussion of changing education is that
people will have a faculty specialist
appointment is frustrating to you but
there's actually there's emotional
investment
and meaning it moves a lot to me it's
the system that shows that it's a system
they're committed to and he's being
criticized by you therefore you're gonna
get a hold on this question so asking
for forgiveness rather than permission
one of the downsides is that so now
let's do it and then talk about it later
so I think so yeah definitely something
right away
but if you wanna make any larger team
just like for example Chaney came out
something that you think
and somebody downstream really wants
that well it's important to the bunny
beforehand discussed beforehand
otherwise if there's emotional and
meaning investment the way things are
done they will be able to listen and
then surprisingly the change factor
change they won't be able to listen to
your factual arguments then because
they're activated emotional and
meaningless boxes so you want to try to
arrange suit those things beforehand and
get all those out in the open first
so I would say for smaller changes yeah
for larger changes it's important to
have people join think about multitude
which is true and that's why when I
deliver be chose the final political
barriers that education affects
political barriers has the occasion that
it's a political problem
I'd say social problem is a collective
problem and any collective problem has
these issues
by yourself
yes it's that the bow so where does the
distance coming strike you today
the dissonance is what you try to reduce
by changing your view so increasing
group feet there's really little
distance because the experiments boring
and they did the experiment they did the
recruiting because indicate there's no
distance here the experiments boring so
they don't have the resolution that oh
I'd be paid doing so they had to have
some way of reducing that distance and
the way they and they're going out the
crew to people so they do it is they
reduce the distance between the internal
and external performance by obtain their
there are what does it mean yeah I don't
want to crazy people think just do it
yeah yeah it's really you're trying to
find collective solutions to problems
look here's a problem I see what do you
think I mean they might agree with you
when I pretty much gentlemen people say
yeah the students are fine and promising
when they have to go do something that
it began to so you can get a much
widened or even on that statement I
don't what to do about it but you could
start there
okay well what do you think we should do
about it they may have some ideas they
may accept the idea that well this is a
serious problem and it's not clear what
to do about it but that right away to
give you some license attracts
so you say okay well here's one thing
I'm thinking is trying to see how it
works so you're not saying it must be
done this way this is the only way to do
it you're bad I'm not going to say well
I'm gonna try this let's see how it
works but I'm happy to share the results
with you and you can use that too and so
there's another related point to that
which is being percentage
so 10% of people will be early adopters
they're really curious about other
priorities but they're open to these
kind of things so when you pop in
someone quickly figure out which
category very if they're probably have
relatives in the family
we need just agree we're not going right
so I haven't I'm sure I mean some people
standing all right back to we just say
who's not gonna talk about that because
one or the two of us it's not going to
doesn't matter what thus it doesn't just
think it's absurd so there's so if
someone's in that category don't even
spend any time to spend your time since
then I've already said okay time to move
on if they're in this category usually
be figured out how to cook the to work
with them and if they're in this
category that's the people who can reach
if you do things in a good way and it's
actually pretty large seventies this is
called a silent majority what sort of
scale exchanges you're talking about
presidents and also along with that how
much power each individual professor has
to design around of course if you figure
out to what the prerequisites architects
course then I don't see exactly what the
problem is so so the question what size
scale changes in my copyright well it
depends how much freedom you have
depends on the changing market for
example suppose you took to heart some
of the readings that were today you
thought was rated for the tower and you
wanted to just just dispense a creative
completely well even if you're teaching
all the right stuff that will raise a
lot of high and even come after that you
may be teaching everything writing and
doing all the free range because it will
trigger all kinds of factual
and it'll go against many many unless
what I'm gonna talk about thanks to
features of American society I think we
must do things that right so you have
less freedom to do something like that
even if you're medium I'm pretty right
now if you want to for example use
different example teach the same ideas
today it won't complete freedom so it
really depends what I want to do then
there are many scales we make change so
you may find that there isn't any way to
do what I want to do and all the
pre-record next course because it just
means doing way too much stuff okay well
now we have the problem of a bigger
scale change how you get the whole group
faculty or people charge at that rate of
course to change I changed the
prerequisites change the overall so now
you're definitely there's another
certain dichotomy which is is the course
requirement this of course isn't
required you have much more freedom
there must be is sort of your course if
people don't like it then have to take
and even if other people don't like your
course or fill things that have work
they're perfectly happy to need to let
you teach the courses on the exact court
because they want to be networks which
you may be but now the require courses
so that every single hundred
let's take those who they are for the
garden more jealously and so cheese than
those of harder and generally require
more consent from other people just
because it's considered a shared core of
the field and by so that's the we and by
changing that you're implicitly grabs
threatened you share core
so what I'm going to talk about after
the break so this was the idea of kind
of dissonance and sort of low blow and
maybe just a few Union your local group
the department maybe your school
difficulties and hospital issues that
come up when you're going to make
educational change I'm gonna talk about
after the break is society-wide featured
to American society you're saying
European American society in general
that imposed really large hospitals
educational change somebody's even
bigger than this one you definitely want
to take the town of this one's there's
also important to take the kind of a
larger scale box and those will be
behaviorism Taylorism and the history
and courtesies and Papa that was after
its 9:58 my doubts of the start at 10:08
personal factors that preceded
individual people but there are also
features that are common across certain
call the social psychology or social
tendencies and the first one is
behaviors so that it's the psychology
you know which basically in America
throughout Pavlov's work on conditioning
dogs we're teaching pages invited award
and punishment in psychology but it was
with a focus on helpless
so it basically denied the importance of
studying what's going on inside the mind
it was correlated with what's called the
same time and student after was devised
a party cares so if you why he came out
of meet annex was that you knew the
is what's called an absurd doing says
look don't talk about what's not
important thing is what's an observable
and everything is sort of a religion
around preservatives all right so
behaviour psychology it was almost in
the same way about the mine we don't
know what the mind is maybe has no
separate existence such as talked about
behaviour what you how does what you do
affect what you are these does and now
that it's a fine way of training pigeons
but it's not a great way to understand
some people's and actually but you can
see there's actually dominant in lots of
American education so the image that was
actually strong within America it was
eventually I would say demolished as an
intellectual movement you Skeeter's both
on behaviorism and that was that's
considered the coup de Gras behaviors
but even then the ideal design and it
underlies so much of what goes on in
schools that actually
maybe one more back shot this was a
study this was fifth sixth and seventh
grade no fourth fifth and sixth graders
and they weren't asked
well what's 6 times 3 that it's 18 they
were asked to make a story problem 6
times 3 equals 88 evil 8% of the
students my story problems were so they
could actually do the problem to make a
problem we use that application that was
difficult for them and they came up with
problem most of the problem so enjoy my
job
okay so there was a fundamental lack of
understanding of what's going on behind
me acquaint so the performance is fine
he said what's the exact 3:15 but it so
the observable was located so by the
either standard that was finalized no
problem and so much of it was on school
which maybe just looks at the outburst
whereas if you have to look into the
mind but the behavior of stimuli
shouldn't we do ask a question find
actually hasn't a week right it's just
like
well interact well what you're doing is
you're textplus zyggie zyggie we think
produces this just if they produce a
correct story as a 1422 then we be happy
either
so in some way you want to know does
this at meeting for them so you clip
then say well 6 times 3 is 18
ok they understood back now I want them
done give me the right output of a story
about why they have we memorize the
correct story but whenever they see
multiplication do this kind of story
well the multiplication is pretty
similar to division so let me see if
they can I see if they understood
multiplication me they just write down
73 you
be kind of pointless to try to have to
memorize all questions likeness but even
have they've seen this kind of question
yeah they might produces the right topic
human and just tell them you see this
when to be four guys here and for their
or you sent me three here well that's
different to really understanding
multiplication so I would say but you're
not making the conclusion you're not
seeing given the output is fine but
you're making inferences about what's
going on behind our behavior so you're
saying oh there's an understanding
that's meaning there's reasoning going
on beyond the outlets and that's what
the neighbors don't want to talk about
they just want to talk about just the
apples and that's a fundamental problem
because real understanding because just
helpless focus on just outlets leads to
road learning and I think that is one of
the explanations for why there's so much
for learning produced in America
you
today was the operation for that
different
yeah well that's not the premise of that
campus over do you need prop people to
just solve problems or make up problems
that can't be the premise I would say
that democratic society well so
independent so on the heights of Maui
many schools there is test it just test
things like that King sort of no child
that's how I that has pretty much any
that's totally be tested preventable by
their basic skills and so there's other
questions and things
so some people care and these kind of
tests are an impediment to making any
kind of change because start pretty
spending time on things like that well
there you have less time to practice a
three digit by five is multiplication
that may be true so the comment was that
maybe it's better to try something not
so hard as making up the story problem
it shouldn't be that part
it shouldn't be that hard in his heart
if you've just done drill yeah angry so
it's not saying that all seven now
unless I'm also not a celebrity this
question how to make a story broke but
if this is used as an example to show
how far from lightning
it's out now why is it so behaviorism is
out safe granted reward and Punishment
is pretty much demanded in American
society everything the discussions of
merit pay for teachers okay where we
should give teachers higher pay if their
students do better on a test from a
child left behind so that is the
assumption that you want more help from
the teacher in a correct you just pay me
more money give me more pigeon food but
there actually may be other reasons
going on there may be completely other
factors besides they put out for example
maybe teachers then
to test this way maybe there's all kinds
of social considerations which aren't
included be just people entertaining
people
apparently so then you can see how red
it is because we would say no you
shouldn't do that to teachers people
think crazy they say well of course we
should so you know we're going to teach
you karate and action research analyst
or variable rate and that's because it's
not receptive pregnancy-related
challenging angry and like I think we're
doing the people get made action does
oh so there's the school so where's but
it doesn't so it's a combination in
respect salary and relate to that
economy so the teachers in America can
we have a look at least a time compared
to say Western European countries so one
way to measure that is time
teachers have to do the critical so in
fact your own my school how many classes
did your teacher teach
typically six today I mean I'm exhausted
if I teach two classes but because it
really takes energy to teach a class
really well think about how to prepare
answer the questions follow up with what
happened we references teaching six
times a days or server and there's no
all you can do is just try to survive so
again another is is another social about
eighteen fifty years
18:56 to make it 50 so what he did he's
the originator of kind of motion styles
so kind of motion studies Ernie watch
how someone for example is riveting
bolts onto a car and you watch every
single movement and come on say oh
actually if you have a screwdriver on
this side well then when the car door
comes down this way to do this is much
more emotion than trying to do that
missing brick every task down into lots
of little little fragments leading
popular now this basically took the
whole country by storm by in the 90 days
or so now how did that happen well this
was a time of unrest and unions were
striking demanding higher wages and
there was then there was interstate
commerce efficient
there's mr. the railroad attorney louis
brandeis later Supreme Court justice
argues economy the Interstate Commerce
Commission well actually we don't have
to raise fares and we can actually give
the union's some of what they want
without going into that provided me
Eagleman Taylor system so the idea of
Taylor system was a way of this week
trying to prevent the unity was striking
but still keep you know not me
distribute any wealth for management but
just make things more efficient
so it was what's called the company was
moving that called cult of officials and
this called the efficiency I would say
probably could only happen you know
frontier society looks at the effect on
European society of the European
discovery around 1500 BC along the sale
and all the explore yourself so what
happened but before 1500 Europe was
extremely crowded lots of people
very few resources very plot was a very
little land pretty much before
knowledge fuel and so the fireplace the
with the discovery the discovery of the
new world that switched there was now a
ton of land and not enough people
especially actually eating it's all
about smallpox in value there was a ton
of natural resources wood minerals
eventually oil so around 1500 the world
society and with it changed conceptions
of how society should work and in the
frontier society basically everything is
there for the taking
you just have to work together so in a
frontier society its need work well the
religion that was the religion of the
frontier society and you can still see
that in America how many weeks of
holidays do people have complete
guaranteed I theta zero right and
whereas in it was four weeks maybe
statutory minimum and Germany it's five
or six weeks so when the frontier
society work will be over vision and
it's likely to be a place where ideas
Taylorism will grow and sprout and drop
so terrorism spread throughout an entire
country you hook into schools and you
can still see in school is considered
Factory and the inputs are the students
and one do that efficiently as possible
in class size giant building new economy
of scale narrating we produce more
product so this one here are the
examples of tailor school was that
platoon school so they were they
enrolled ten percent to 70 percent more
children than there are seats further
classified okay so now this how they
achieve this efficiency this is done
site dumping the ten percent to 70
percent on the playground into the
auditorium or basement and by keeping
all the children rotating for rooby-roo
teacher the teacher so the same ten
percent to 70 percent we not detect
waiting longer than thirty per second in
minutes and get into classrooms so even
the sixth row of children of 67 teaches
the day as many as twelve or thirteen in
some cities the teachers handle as many
as four hundred peoples in the day of a
thousand a week
so the terrorists came to the school and
said hey look these schools are there
you know I felt very wrong to have small
schools for people but these competition
look there's all this inefficiency you
could squeeze out of the system right
and so you see probably my teeth
the budget cuts all the cabling to stand
upon us and try to squeeze some light I
mean the inefficiency so what they said
was they said oh look they're all these
rooms and our key use right have the gym
that's not use all the time that's
lunchroom that's only used you know
lunchtime that's crazy like there's an
empty room there there's a playground
that's been used at recess
right and what we should do is we should
rotate the kids all the way through it
you like to see that in the schools now
they have a lunch period many of them
have a much greater that starts at like
10:00 a.m. and lunch period goes till
almost 2:00
because it's a much more efficient use
of the lunchroom and but ironically they
have canceled recess because recess
isn't efficient as recess is not
appreciative of standardized test
problems so you don't see that as well
so in the call the efficiency that was
back in the 20s I've heard that quote I
read in from it's from Raymond Callahan
for public education and the cult of
efficiency a study of historical forces
that have shaped administration of
public school but it continues to today
in No Child Left Behind we see is a
perfect example the long run mother
wrote
said the long lines of Martian children
are going to be like nothing so much as
the lines
four cars in the factory moving always
mine with a screw put on our earth
tightness they pass standardized
mechanical pinnacle was the factory
system cabinet in the public school
which needs only the closing time
missile to make completeness
identification with giant great
industrial plants so there you have
another fundamentally important to the
eaters of the killer sort of all
together which is the joining of the
school on the back an educational system
so education in America was one of the
leading countries in this in making
schools free and requires compulsory
education public schools so this in
Massachusetts actually our state was the
leading state in our communities and so
Horace Mann in the 1840s leading
educational reformers and he was arguing
to businessman occasionally who's
willing to have higher taxes to make
schools free and require
why don't people want to buy businesses
want to part with their profits to pay
for schools well he said look there's
all these benefits from schools the
school worker are more docile and
quickly apply themselves to work they
have better domestic and social habits
infidelity for school
which is that so I experienced this
firsthand one day in my high school this
lace this student attacked me and called
me nasty names and so when I fought back
to be sort of fought to a draw because
trying serious damage and then as a
result the school policy was that
whoever was in the fight was suspended
for three days so we were both my
madness expanded in Manhattan to the
court to figure out
okay so I suspended for three games when
I had to find out whether the policies
with me to school so it was very
interesting so first of all if you're
relating to school three times you know
what when you fail for that quarter okay
if you're if you fail the second quarter
of a semester you failed semester if you
fail the second semester of course you
they gonna be entire year and if you
fail the required course like English
then you fail the entire year that
repeat all great okay so they were very
very very stickler about time fallible
but anybody care what you're raised with
that but you get C's and DS I'm testing
you can do much better than if you
missed four days of school now I can sir
who nice in this case is about don't
worry about good thing [ __ ] and stood up
for yourself we only do any of that
stuff
there's always a puzzling to me why
punctuality is so much more important in
his public school and then the accident
rate you got how much you learn and when
I read the history of course man oh yes
that actually makes perfect sense the
purpose of the school wasn't necessarily
to teach people to think they really
understand it was the social things to
be behind it was to produce people who
were lately dos
protectors which was just coming around
40
so there were many comments along those
lines one of the arguments also go to
schools similarity medals a resolution
that the best police for our cities the
lowest insurance of our houses the
firmest security for our banks the most
effective means of preventing poppers
and vice and crime and the only sure
defense of our country are our common
schools I mean they need the public
resources that are required so any was
seen as a defense of property and this
was true so when I say America it's not
just America England in London 1870
passing Education Act required public
school for school and the arguments in
England were almost exactly the same
would nonetheless would be better
employed in assisting the work of the
schoolmaster by collecting together for
school attendance willfully neglected
children who are springing up into
recruits with a great army of crime and
there and what we prevent the working
classes from engaging with those main
strikes which ended 99 have 100 we
condemn the worst condition and for what
would keep them from habits and wasting
the province with some knowledge of the
six-second of Manson
education supply notice education as
possible so history of education it
still hurts and people are very open
about this these weren't no secret
documents and people vote in America
conspiratorial council if these were
openly discussed they notice of I should
pay for school Jose was even quite a
statistic recently sophisticated level
so willingly fuel he was naturally
Trinity College Cambridge so when he was
a university professor everyone in that
community he was commenting on the
differences in the European and they say
English an American education system he
said well actually they had another
problem in Europe and problem lies my
father so he was recommending the
teaching of mathematics so the
mathematical dog things are fixing him
and permit no new system of geometry can
supersede you only so
whoops Romanian use some apricot
bassinet the fix the consultation of
mathematics was not likely to promote
the critical spirit life in France and
Germany there are too much attention
into the more provisional and
contentious observational Sciences had
been partly responsible for the inland
and general hostility to the existing
institutions of their country swing
there were three sheep teaching
mathematics because it has one answer
basically nice we want people to
conclude about society to DES the one
answer which is the society in cap
whereas if you teach observational
Sciences Social Sciences people might
start questioning too much though there
was not to school for what should we
teach in our schools so that history is
very very hard to overcome because it's
so deeply been into the foundation in
the school we will find these purposes
like that no such purpose is creeping up
there all schools have to buy the school
sure the school could tell students look
you're not learning this idea very well
spend more time on that
that kind of evaluation for the students
benefit it's quite useful but why should
that be publicized to other people
well that was our two separate questions
but they're automatically plated because
the party and the purpose of the school
is to get people to accept their place
in the society there's a very
interesting experiment along the track
today what they did is they made they
also they came into the class and they
say eighty-three craters just found out
that the older the more intelligent the
private show and so we have to teach
them a circle so then separated into two
classrooms and they talk exactly the
same stuff and then they tested them
while later they found the blue-eyed
children did much much better in the
ground so the sure the test results must
be correct so then we screwed up and
actually better actors
it was the brown eyed children or more
Intel and then the blue-eyed children so
we have to switch the classrooms so they
switch the classrooms of course they're
talking exactly the same stuff and when
you've been happy with the technical
ones they flip in case affects the
example of the effective track of the
great so what's the result of that is
that whilst
then accept their place they think oh
yes you know I am too dumps dude I am
the back Peter well I'm just not so good
is that you know it's my fault right
rather than well it's the way it's
taught it's that you know I came from a
family where we just didn't have much
money and food and the society was to
provide that so I was hungry there so
there's all kinds of social excavations
which are not to look at and even the
very problems that are done in schools
came to reinforce the social order but
if so an example that actually showed
how strong that tendency is well look at
the problems that are done about
percentages the percentage problems are
almost always in the following form
johnny has a thousand dollars which he
lands to jail six percent he knows how
much interest does Jane pay for two
years first of all John next month the
guy
the borrower so now with feminism we've
made it so that changing out of money
but haven't changed my mental problem is
that the problem is means worth in the
idea of money which isn't what about the
halting problem which you never see
which is lovely percentage of the hourly
minimum wage is $7 an hour or something
where it's going hours of meat what's
their salary it's this much it's roughly
14,000 what percentage of the federal
poverty violence will be housed here
that's a percentage of all but it has a
different sort of message so the schools
have chosen basically the social
pressures that push there was one kind
of problem one kind of grading one kind
of system and and this is despite where
people know about these things so we
should what's the momentum affected
actually another examples is traffic so
tracking where people go that is
apartment so a friend of mine you are to
mention the meat products the smaller
ones by the school and one year they
decided you seduce traffic so tracking
is advanced math medium math located
immediately and after a year there was a
parental revolt and Dave Wallace the
parent said this is outrageous
we're not
for you to tell us for you to tell our
kid that kid is not intelligent to get
rid of all right where is this perfect
route Center perfect step will be back
to kids in public schools so people know
yet the thing goes on so then whenever
something like you see something
happening we can bet there's some really
purposes and rush the site so these
agencies they're not immunity also the
factors have changed in the past and all
of them can change again but in origin
and it's important to be America
well I think you've identified a
fundamental problem which is the the
competition and so we can sort of like
the water you know sit on one side of
the water that the other side there's
episode introduce the companies in one
place it might be who's in other way so
for example you have an overrated in
high school and you
hi state university entrance exam it's
not necessarily the ideal solution and I
think the ideal solution is that you
make good universities accessible
ultimately or for example you make it so
that you don't need a university degree
to earn a meager salary this
well that was quote Margaret Mead on
that never underestimate the power of a
so all things that we now think are
served and just horrible we're once more
slavery was in fact of inferior races
but all these things that we think are
horrible now for sure are not considered
just beyond the pale because of social
movements so my main point here is that
these are structural fundamental large
issues and they require structural large
society life changes fundamentally
change them but good little ways the
school's themselves produce people who
being forced to social structures so
when people had come through the do I
promise experiment and they feel
themselves that they are not worthy
there are less likely to try to make a
social change to make a just society
okay so it goes both ways
improving the schools
society society it's a great point - the
point was creepy take advantage of the
poetic that - I experiment to just tell
people look never mind this glass feels
great and so just actually many people
do well by their arse actually a fair
amount of data so Craig wasn't raised in
exactly that way the example I'm
thinking of is women's colleges it's a
large portion of women in science PhDs
come from all over the college and I
think that's partly that effect
it shouldn't expect in the regular
society women are generally told Luca
doing the particle that was taken off as
it was drawn there was a particle that
for a while said Oh
math math is hard I don't do math or
something like that so there was a huge
outcry amantha take it some people did
spoofs take what but that is king
but that so cool attitude does sort of
permanent exciting it it's much less
than women's all-women's colleges so
police Lexmark Mart or anymore
Smith where it's not so but I think that
is a reason for not criticize kids you
know when you're raising their children
or plantations
don't criticize them and the same with
the Iranian University creating should
be so the students can figure out what
they need to learn more but not as a big
deal that that's so our degree for so
long
I would say concern but yeah
well okay so the question of competition
I so question ok so there's so if we
continue what the rest of what Einstein
said so remember before I said that one
had the crime all crammed all the stuff
with the ones mind little I'm like it or
not this career is such an eternity
affected after I passed the final exam
if I'm the consideration it is in fact
nothing short of a miracle that the
modern methods of instruction have not
entirely Strang and Khloe seriously
required this delicate little plant
aside from stimulation stands mainly and
even freedom without this opposed to
rack and doing about failures so I hope
that you know when you're having the
world
be your teaching and amazing your
children death find ways to make more
freedom in education so that the
students actually that you produce
improve the society and they and can
help you improve the schools and
education
okay the question about competition it
is a fundamental point about competition
for resources this you have to really
get to make a radical analysis the
radical lattices to the root to the root
of the problem the problem you can see
it in the extreme case India where there
are so to use there are so many people
and so if you observe the comfortable
jobs and then move to their comfortable
job is an indication that there is an
intense competition for tutors in the
office not because people want to learn
but because that's the means to actually
not starving but but so what that shows
is that we not everyone wants to learn
with a tutor differential equations but
a lot of people are learning the kinds
of players with the tears because that
means they'll get a degree which means
to confess
so part of the issue is redistributing
the wealth of the society so that
they're comfortable whether or not we've
had a tutorial of differential equations
or my tutorial then when when the fears
are taken away people are much more
likely to do things for intrinsic
reasons so the people who really
understand that and do that if people
are really interested in teaching that
will teach that and you'll have a much
you'll have a redirection of social
resources much more productive quick the
better part is example the body was a
guaranteed income in terms of health
care they even guaranteed basic
schooling for everyone so that those
things aren't teachers a connotation
I don't know about that so a good
example of a business system based on
competition self-regulate not sure about
that we make mortgage derivative market
example that actually what happened was
the engineering firms so you had some
sort of slowpoke banking system feedback
loops left half-plane
nice decay constant and then the
competition to make more money quickly
well one way to make more money was a
trader but quicker and that quicker
what did that he would increase the
gaming the feedback groups they shut out
the polls this way and eventually some
of the world's across the axis and you
got a huge amount many oscillations we
grew huge isolation on a whole bunch of
bankers so it's actually not necessarily
true that this competition is celebrated
because they're all these month we are
has a feedback system no guarantee of
that and one of the harmful combination
is people against each other and when
she'd much rather have is people working
together and helping each other because
as studies supported by
well we already have all kinds of ways
we do have regulations to do for example
say I mean income tax and the social way
of deciding what's worthwhile and what's
not you can say okay we're going to tax
people think
and we're gonna use that money to pay
that's the sort of shorter because say
this teacher's salary to this so that if
you think it's a worthwhile thing to do
we can say look look we think rich thing
is really important we're going to
social choices just like and does that
be pushed back so we can change our
education system that would to be no
barrier to it is that our thoughts are
limited by the educational system that
we went through so in one way that's bad
news because there's this giant feedback
you keeping things the way they are on
the other hand because there's a
feedback the educational system affects
the society vice versa well it means you
can work anywhere on the feedback if you
want
okay
answers from lecture tend to questions
generated in lecture 9
okay lots of questions from last time so
I won't answer all of them because
otherwise we'll probably spend the
entire time just on the questions from
last time all right which maybe I should
have anticipated since it's a it's a
central topic and one that connects to
not just education but directly to
society the topic on political barriers
educational change so I'll answer some
of those but then I wanted to also give
you a chance to ask any questions that
have been unresolved that have come up
in your teaching so or that you think
might come up in your teaching so one of
my old teachers Donald Knuth always
reserved the last session for student
questions and I think it's a really good
philosophy to basically tie everything
together tie all the loose ends up so I
call it your turn okay but partly part
of your turn was answering some of your
questions from before his social
education a bad thing and so the comment
was I'm still not convinced that social
education is a bad thing I obviously it
gives a lot of control to whoever gets
to make the decision of what constitutes
a good citizen but some of the social
agendas in public schooling were good
for example diversity recycling all
right and that's true so it's not that I
don't want to be misinterpreted as
saying society is a bad thing I think
society naturally educates people you
pick up your values from people around
you your parents I'll give you a cycle
norms schools give us norms and I think
it's exactly what the question said it's
that who gets to decide is it you know
some group of elites who decide or is it
the whole society collectively deciding
what they think is good for everybody
and that what's good for everybody may
not be one thing and maybe the decision
is well different people need or want
different things and we think a good
Society is based on the idea that people
have freedom to follow their interests
and also some may be required were
that everyone needs to learn for example
reading but then what you read may be up
to you so yeah I don't think all social
education is a bad thing at all I think
all education is social there's no way
to avoid that that's inherently we're
social animals and it's the question of
what's in that education and it's the
same thing
political barriers to educational change
it's not that politics is inherently a
bad thing it's the question is what kind
of politics do we have and how can we
make that better and more humane so for
example I think recycling is a good
example of making things more humane
okay if competition demotivates some
people doesn't motivate other people
does eliminating competition reduce
maximum performance
other than the studies referred to by
alfie kohn I'm not sure if the answer to
that is known I mean there certainly
there's Studies on how for example
competition leads to a lot of waste the
classic example in economics is suppose
you and this was actually a real example
I suppose you give people what was it it
was 160 acres of land I think that was
the that was a quarter plot or 640 acres
of land way out in the West and the rule
is whoever gets there first gets to
claim that piece of land yeah and you
have to you know put up you get there
and you stick posts up and you put a
fence there that's roughly how the
Homestead Act worked well the problem
with that is it does cause a lot of
waste which is that tons of people might
run out and chase after that land and
make a whole bunch of effort by train
tickets go on a wagon with their whole
family out west but only one person gets
to land so a whole bunch of people
actually put in a lot of wasted effort
so that's a classic example of how
competition can be quite wasteful other
examples where exclusive rights do that
are patents so if as is the case a
patent is only given to one person or
the inventor and you have 15 people or
30 people trying to invent something so
the more the competition in this case
the more waste is going to happen
because all these people are going to
funds but only one person is gonna get
the exclusive right and the other people
are just left high and dry
so there's many examples where
eliminating competition will actually
increase the amount of social wealth
contributed towards useful ends but to
the direct question of whether it
reduces maximum forms I don't know if
that's known no it's the studies in
Alfie cones article pointed to how
competition reduces high level
performance but for example complex
cognitive tests maximum performance
probably one we need to define that
pretty closely and then one can do
Studies on it so there was an
interesting question about the
understanding multiplication so the
understanding multiplication example I
gave where people could multiply 6 by 3
and get 18 but then couldn't come up
with a word problem that used 6 by 3 or
they could but the word problem was
Johnny by 6 apples on Monday he buys 3
apples on Tuesday so 6 times 3 is 18 all
right so that was maybe a bit unfair to
ask students because writing a story
draws on skills beyond mathematical
understanding such as imagination and
language so it's true it does draw on
those skills but I don't think those are
separate for mathematical understanding
if you can't explain the mathematics
that you have in you you don't really
understand it when I was an
undergraduate a friend of mine and I
used to we used to torment that math
grad students it was sort of unfair like
we were really curious about math we
were fascinated by math and we wanted to
know what people do in graduate school
and only later did I realize we were
actually tormenting them we weren't
doing it intentionally we would ask them
okay what are you working on sometimes
we had classes with them or we'd see
them in the math lab and they would say
oh the theorem and you know we were
undergraduates and young and we didn't
really know what the theorem was so we'd
say well can you give us an example and
that produced just
deer-in-the-headlights example example
hmm that was completely foreign and not
at all what they were thinking about is
completely out of their space
and later I actually realized that that
was actually a very fair question and if
you wanted to test whether people
understood what they were working on and
I found that things I can give examples
on I understand and things I can't I
don't understand another example that is
Fineman
he said I've always found that I don't
understand anything unless I can give a
freshman lecture on it or equivalently
people asked him to give a lecture on
something he said no I don't understand
I don't understand that well enough I'll
have to first work out a freshman
lecture on it then I can explain it
better and so there's famous lectures of
his where he's explained antiparticles
and spin and he finally got it to a
level where he thinks that it actually
suitable for a freshman so first-year
college students so it's a brilliant
lecture it's in the if you search for
the Dirac memorial lectures by Fineman
you'll find that lecture there and it's
fascinating so it shows the level of how
hard work it is to actually understand
something in that level and it almost
essentially essential to that process is
examples so examples explaining
understanding I think those are
intrinsic to mathematical understanding
so it wasn't an unfair test it was
actually a test of high-level
mathematical understanding those one
point was made thus worth more is not a
women's college yeah that's true I
mentioned that women's colleges were
much more successful in producing women
PhD students in science and I listed
Bryn Mawr and Smith and then I listed
Swarthmore which was not correct that
was crosstalk between Bryn warrants
worth more I sort of grouped them all
Brin more Haverford and Swarthmore
together so it's worth more is a
co-educational College and it's I I
meant Bryn Mawr and Smith and I was
thinking of Wellesley as well so
Wellesley is a all women's college
unless they've changed lately no okay I
mean every once in a while people
colleges think of changing right but
there's still all women so now people
ask for references and further
information about that so the person the
I'll put a link on the website but it's
Barbara Witten at the Colorado College
physics department she's done the most
extensive Studies on not too
what makes basically what makes for
women being successful in science but in
general what makes for students in say
physics major she was the chair of the
Colorado physics department Colorado
College physics department when I
interviewed there what makes for a
successful graduate major program so
this is quite interesting for people
interested in teaching not just revising
one course but revising the entire
department curriculum so she's done
cross-institutional Studies on the
culture of departments and what makes
what facets of the culture are
responsible for students continuing on
in science and what she's found is that
it's not just so the same features that
help women continue in science help
everybody so I highly recommend her work
and I'll put a link to her webpage on
our course webpage Barbara Witten
I think it's WI tten but it might be whi
tten in the Colorado College physics
department
it's clear that you don't like or me I
don't like No Child Left Behind what
would I do if I were the Secretary of
Education in this country yeah well
he'll would probably freeze over before
that happened but there's a long vetting
process for that before people become
that and you have to show your loyalty
to pretty much every aspect of the
current system before that happens
before you're appointed to such posts
but if hell froze over what would I do
I think one of the fundamental problems
with education is in America is the vast
inequalities in funding in resources so
the wealthy school districts have two
three four times as much funds per
student as the poor school districts and
that's because I mean it has there's a
good part of that I mean that's the
disparities bad but there's a reason for
the disparity and the reason isn't all
bad the reason is that America education
is a local affair it's controlled by
local authorities so in the Constitution
reserves a bunch of powers for the
federal government printing money making
war various things like that then it
says okay then the states can do a bunch
of stuff like for example regulate
voting and then it says anything not
explicitly given to the national or
state governments is given to the people
more in fact I think it says anything
that this would be this is the 11th
amendment I believe I tenth or eleventh
amendment it says especially devolution
it says any powers not given to the
federal government go to the state if
they're given to the state if not given
to the state they go to the people in
other were and so education is in that
category it's nowhere mentioned in the
Constitution education so it's not given
to the states it's not given to the
federal government so in America it's
given to the local authorities now the
problem is that different communities
have different wealth paces you know
there's some very rich suburbs and for a
while the cities were wealthy but then
people fled all the wealthy people
the cities in the 1950s during
suburbanization so the city's the
Centers of cities became very poor so
there is fast disparities in wealth
there and I think one thing is that the
federal government could do is actually
just correct those so they've been
lawsuits along those lines for forcing
state governments to try to correct that
because there are there is some role for
the states in education I'm not sure
where that comes from the Constitution
but that their State Boards of Education
and I think it's Vermont in New Jersey
they've been lawsuits and state courts
to force the states to equalize funding
across school districts so somehow
mitigating the differential and property
tax revenues and I think the federal
government could do that as well so
those lawsuits are based on pretty sure
the Fourteenth Amendment equal
protection of the laws and now there's
no reason the federal government
couldn't do that as well and so I would
do that as step number one no strings
attached like here let's just equalize
the resources and then we can worry
about what we're gonna do after that
where as No Child Left Behind what it
does is it makes the resources actually
more unequal because the school it tests
all the schools and the schools that our
fate I'm gonna do what badly are the
ones with less resources and then
they're gonna get punished for doing
badly so I would take the opposite
approach is there a particular country's
educational system that I particularly
admire it's a good question it's not
okay again I think it's local there's
local educational experiments that I
admire a lot and occasionally larger
scale ones a whole country not so much I
mean there's states in India phrase it
for example for a while Kerala I don't
know if it's still true but had an
incredibly high literacy rate so I think
98 percent which was much higher than
anywhere else in India and matches
literacy levels in the West and this had
many benefits so for example one of the
one study about population is that
population growth is slowed down the
most by educating women and Carol
actually that 98 percent included women
not just men
so I think that's an educational system
worth looking into and places that I
admire their little local pockets the
free schools in the 1960s there's a few
places like that still in America
there's the Sudbury Valley School just I
don't know maybe it's 50 miles west of
here it's inside the Sudbury Valley and
that's modeled on Summerhill one of the
earliest free schools in England so
actually it has it's good and bad so
Summer Hill there's no required classes
and there's no required curriculum and
students you know and the students can
go to class or not or can play outside
so that would work really well I think
that works really well if all the
teachers are really inspiring because
then the students be automatically drawn
in to learn stuff but if the teachers
aren't very skilled then you have
problems with that so I think it worked
mixed there but the potential is good
now the and the freedom is really good
and teaches people to be responsible but
it has its downside so my parents I have
a personal experience with that which is
when I was three so I was born in
England and we lived there for a few
years and then we moved to New Jersey
and when I guess I was 4 maybe my
parents thought about sending me to
England to go to summer Hill because
this was 1973 so it was in the middle of
you know lots of political change in
America free schools were a big part of
the cultural discussion and my parents
believed in those values which I'm glad
they did and they thought okay let's see
about sending Santa at a Summer Hill so
we took a trip back to England and they
visited and I think the way they tell me
what happened was that everything was
fine except then they were wandering
around with the teacher on the tour and
they saw these marks on the door and
they said Oh what are those marks on the
door because I believed in the
philosophy of letting children do what
they want to do and follow their own
interest but they said oh what are those
marks on the door there and they said oh
that's Johnny I
he likes to stand over there and throw
knives at the door
so then my parents thought well maybe
that's just a little too unsupervised
especially if the child is across the
Atlantic from us and it's not really
easy to see how things are going and
intervene if things aren't going so well
now so they decided not to send me to
summer help but they sent me to
progressive nursery schools locally as
well and I have good memories of those
two okay so yeah there's a difference
between I would say there's a
fundamental point in there which is that
there's a difference between freedom and
license and so this is a distinction not
often made so license is the bad pole
and freedom is the good this is how I'm
splitting the two parts so license is
just add do whatever you want I take
drugs you know be a prostitute do
whatever you want you're you're free
well that's not really freedom you're
licensed whereas freedom in my mind has
some intrinsic regulation on it you're
free you're a free creature you have
responsibility to use that freedom well
and license doesn't have any of that
responsibility so I think when one is
designing curricula that you have to try
to make the norm such that freedom is
promoted and not licensed now to some
extent you can't avoid a bit of license
because for example the Summerhill
teachers say that when students come
from regular schools you know where
they've been basically competing with
each other
basically some may be feeling beaten
down some of them come to summer Hill
and just do nothing for a year
they just sit outside and play on the
swings and in the creek just for a year
it takes them a year of detoxification
before they are ready to go back into
the classroom and learn things formally
so you could say that's a bit of license
but maybe that's a bit of a necessary
license or maybe they're actually just
discovering how to use freedom and it
takes them a year because they never had
any practice with that so I think it's
important to keep those two pieces
separate okay so now if there's so many
questions okay so one question so
there's two that I think are
particularly important to discuss so
there were there was a comment that the
one of the alfie kohn readings was
off-putting because
he made comments about the people with
different political views than his and
he seemed like a left wing nut and that
therefore the reading shouldn't be
assigned so yeah I agree that if you
have a quite a different political view
than alfie kohn it can be a bit
off-putting but actually I think that's
a good thing now why is that
it's because it's actually it's
fundamentally important to find views
that challenge you and read them anyway
so as you probably guessed most of my
views are not mainstream so I do that
all the time whether I like it or not
just when I open the paper or if I
happen to watch television which I
actually don't hardly at all but if I
open the newspaper or were read things
just right next to my office there was a
there's a teaching magazine I forget
what it's called prison may mean I
forget the name of the magazine but it
sits on the magazine display and I just
was walking by and turned my head this
way to read the title on the front cover
and it said students coach it was it go
oh yeah
cash incentives proven are proving
successful promote it for promoting
student learning so this was against
everything I believe in so if I had time
I'll actually read the article but you
know I'm surrounded by things I disagree
with and I think that's actually pretty
healthy so if you disagree with an
article read it all the way through the
danger of not doing that and the law
professor casts Cass Sunstein from
Chicago who's talked about as being a
possible Supreme Court nominee by Obama
he's written eloquently about the
dangers of not doing that and he said
because it wasn't so possible say 50
years ago there was large circulation
newspapers and maybe two or three in
each town and people read those those
are calm there was a common discourse
through that but now everyone can get
their own particular news on the
internet I didn't get your own views
from this small Journal or from that
particular newspaper or this person
writing an article that you happen to
agree with and the danger is of people
just collecting into small little micro
communities we
where each community just agrees with
itself and only reads things and
discusses things that they agree with
and that's very unhealthy for democracy
he points out which i think is right so
I think it's very important to actually
seek out things you disagree with and so
if I happen to give you a reading that
at first you disagreed with it's not
such a bad thing and it's actually it
belongs for sure in an academic
curriculum because that's one of the
purposes of an academic curriculum you
know the word University comes from it
has uni in it one so the idea is is this
one universe all ideas are open
discussion okay even ones we disagree
with okay so let's see there was okay
then the lated one is I find it
off-putting when I put my personal
biases and opinions is absolute for
example programming and this is related
to the last point program latex may be
easier and more convenient for me but
it's possible to develop familiarity
with other software and systems that
makes them close to equivalent if not
equivalent but that may be true though I
think there's fundamental reasons to
wonder about it just because for it's by
not programmed by not using a system
such as latex or tech any what's common
about all of them is that you program
them and by not using a system like that
you give up the ability to program and
that is a huge loss just as you can see
it how much can computers do the way
computers are so powerful is because we
program them and how the fundamental
recipe for programming is at least when
I teach it is this
so this is how this is the fundamental
idea of programming so you do something
and then you do it again
and when you're doing it again you're
like oh I just did this maybe I should
write a program now I'm too lazy but
then the third time it happens again
you're like okay
bloody hell this time ready program okay
so basically the recipe is the third
time you're about to do something don't
do it write a program to do it so now
you have a little mini program that you
can reuse now it's a new module and you
can use that module to build still new
programs you can build a huge Tower of
abstraction so for example in the figure
drawing program you can actually write
programs that generate trees and then
you can write a five line script and you
say okay feed that to my tree generating
program and it'll make a tree that
you've been using your figures in your
talks or in your books so I'll post a
few examples of that the input has a
five line tree and the output PDF so
that is much so the first time you write
that program it takes longer than doing
it graphically no question which is why
this second part happens because you do
it sort of the slightly hard way the
first time you don't realize the second
time you're like oh there's something in
common here and but it's too late I just
have to do it the slightly hard way the
third time you say ok finally I'm gonna
do it with a program so I think there
are fundamental reasons to I think that
if you can program your documents you'll
also be more efficient now that actually
may end up not being true I suspect it
is but it may not be but even if it
isn't take it as not an absolute but as
a suggestion to try in your own work and
in your own writing ok and I don't mean
it as an absolute ok so now there's ten
more questions but I'm gonna leave them
for now and if at the end we haven't
used up all the time of questions I'll
continue in some of those questions